all right enough talking about [__]
internet fights angry people angry
people I want to talk about real
fights real men what um because uh I had
a mate come visit me in Thailand uhhuh
and uh I took to
a well we might we might have got we
might have done with the amount of
[__] adrenaline running through our
veins okay cuz I took him to a Muay Tha
fight oh [__] yeah and it was actually
my very first Muay Thai like see my very
first Muay Thai fight I've seen it a lot
onv never actually like gone out of my
way to watch a fight in real life um and
I don't know something something uh next
time you guys are in Thailand I got to
[__] take you in one because
something clicked in my brain that I
didn't know was there um it's like I
just want to kick a dude yeah yeah so so
basically uh we got like ringside seats
uh to one it was it was a Sunday event
so it was like a it was a televised
event sure right um and watching two men
just [__] beat the [__] out of each
other uh and sitting why think Bey so
popular I don't [__] like I okay I've
I've seen fights I've seen like boxing
I've seen contact Sports before and it's
like cool in the moment and you're like
I'm okay I don't know I I I like it I
can I can watch it but I'm not like into
into it but like just see being ringside
and just hearing every single punch and
just seeing the sweats you know you know
in you know in [__] Sports Anime or
like you know a sports film where it's
like someone gets punched and you see
like The Sweat Just explode everywhere
like seeing that in real life made me
realize why like you know it made me
feel like being a Roman watching like
going to the Coliseum some [__] like
that this is the closest I've seen to
like real blood Sports up close sure and
uh uh yeah
just I'm I'm I'm like a bit I I guess
Muay Tha is like pretty popular right
but it's not as obviously it's not as
widespread in televised as it is in
Thailand and it is just such a fun
contact sport where oh I bet I I was
there and I was like I don't know if
we're going to see some good matches or
not we had we had um eight eight matches
um four of them ended out ended up in
Knockouts like oh damn wow hell yeah
yeah and and I was uh talking to one of
the event organizers and they were like
oh yeah today was a pretty tame day
actually oh my God like that today was a
pretty tame day brain damage the
sport not a single broken bone what te
no I literally I've seen so many I've
seen so many [__] Joe Rogan Clips
talking about like the brutality of Muay
Tha and then seeing like like you you
get to a point where there's there's an
opportunity where if if a guy gets hit
right you will literally you have a
chance of getting [__] blood in your
blood in your uh beer or some [__] like
that it is it is in your beer yeah yeah
it is it is that like it is that brutal
and they and they go that hard but also
there a bunch of Tai guys just like
sitting there being like wasn't the same
today no blood in my beer no blood in my
beer yeah I don't know there's just
something bringing the Poncho yeah
raincoat yeah but uh yeah so it was it
was my first Muay Tha experience and I I
I honestly think now that everyone
should go see cuz like you went to see
the you went you got to see sit ringside
on the YouTuber chess boxing right I did
yeah F how how much of an adrenaline
rush did you get from watching that I
mean it's just intense and you feel bad
you almost feel bad for the people cuz
you can hear all the punches connecting
on TV you don't hear that yeah but you
hear the like all the little noises and
it almost makes it like worse and better
at the same time CU you're like it makes
you really uncomfortable with the idea
of watching people just beat the [__]
out of each other yeah um that's how I
felt when we went to go see the Sumo as
well like I've seen it on TV so many
times but just especially that first
initial impact of when the match starts
it is so loud there is just there is
just this like kind of awe that I think
people and humans just have with beating
each other up or sports that require you
to throw each other around or something
something in your monkey that's why
world star is a thing something in your
monkey brain that just sees two people
hitting each other like I remember this
one I remember this one fight where um
there's this one guy who just seemed to
be tanking kicks yeah right I like every
everyone in there is hard as a [__]
hard as a [__] I use hard in
like the [__] British way yeah hard
as a [__] um like they like
there are we we went we went on a day
was that was meant to be like the
amateur fights right and these amateur
fights there were these like 16 18y olds
that have been in 40 matches at
the they they literally felt like a
characters cuz you see this 16-year-old
walk in and you're like dad is just he
been fighting with his dad the night
before I actually I actually cuz uh me
and my mate had a few drinks before and
and he posed this question to me right
he was like all right Real Talk how many
8-year-olds do you think you can feasy
beat in a fight like H how like what's
what's number all attacking yeah if
you're if they were all attacking you at
the same time how many eight-year-olds
do you think you can beat in the I think
after 10 I'm done would youan you're
satisfied no no no as in like I'll be
dead do they have weapons no no no all
just just fist all hand to-and combats I
think after 10 it'll get too
overwhelming you think you can take on
10 because here here's the thing right
here's the thing I don't know how
skilled are these 8-year-olds I feel
like I could beat up a lot more than 10
yeah okay listen the if okay the one the
one thing that would hold you back is
would your hands start hurting too much
after punching so many kids in the face
yeah but you assume okay here's the
thing right okay what am I assuming what
am I assuming I'm missing something you
assume that you can deck a kid and he
will stay down in one hit right cuz
that's that's the thing if if there are
too if there are too many 8-year-olds
that like jump you at the same time
they're going to eventually overpower
you right yeah that's true actually so
you like the the Strat is am allowed to
kick yeah you're allowed to kick you can
do whatever the [__] you want they're
dunzo the the Strat is can you can you
like can you completely knock out one
kid in one hit and how many times can
you do that in a row cuz if they get up
they're eventually just going to [__]
drag you down you out it's going to be
like an arcade machine each one they
come near me I'll kick them in Oblivion
just just coffee grind sweep all their
legs out and they just go one by one
these the legs that did the cycon these
have big legs I it's like the force of
Zeus in this kid's face like Mich like
uh like Atlas if you put down the bow
and start throwing hands it's like that
scene in
300 dude I mean I I think I could knock
out a kid instantly what do you mean but
think that's you don't think you could
knock out a kid instantly why do why
like this is the most trash T discussion
here we're logistically talking about
child 8-year-old 8-year-old what do the
what the average weight and size of an
8-year-old bring it up I want to be
scien that's why I said 10 cuz I think I
think like think I do 30 iy old and then
give me a five minute give me a five
minute uh I think 8-year-olds can get
stronger than you think give me a give
me like a i this is why games like
realistic battle simulator the [__]
question can I get that in real units
please yeah no no pounds no pounds
because if they as long as they I mean
obviously they'd be hitting my balls 20
kilos
yeah that's one hand 20 to 30 kilos dude
I can launch 20
kilos I could throw a kid into the into
the other kids and keep throwing them
around yeah but i' get tired that'd be
the biggest thing my stamina you would
get tied right so so what's going to run
out first the Vitality of these kids
like I'm not talking about how many
8-year-olds oneon-one fight can you do
in a row I'm talking about they try they
try to jump you and you have to like
strategically try to take on what's my
Battlefield what's what's my battle all
right what's the math where am I
fighting I really want Super Smash Bros
Final Destination no items yeah yeah
yeah right it's a flat ground flat
ground I can jump to a platform though
right there's a platform above me
no was literally just just flat flat
ground it's like it's like a [__]
I just have to EDG guard them and
they're done you're in a park and and
and these kids are like you know they're
not built like a backy character but
happening to what happen our trash St it
doesn't matter we're talking about real
discussions here real discussions with I
said 10 right because I think like five
for instance right is I think is doable
right I mean it won't be easy but I
think it'll be doable I think five is I
think 10 though is the limit where like
if there's 10 8-year-olds running up to
you in all directions how are you going
to start just think about this can I
kill them okay
okay yeah yeah you can kill them but but
let's assume these are like not real
kids these aren't real kids these are
like what's the most effective way
that's what I'm saying coffee grind
coffee grind just coffee grind sweep out
all their feet so they fall to the
ground and then just take them on one by
one this feels like a fear and hunger
enemy actually your foe in the dungeon
15 kids 15 kids armored up cuz we had
this discussion then he posed me the
question okay but like would you like
would you think the same if they were
monkeys could you think about monkeys
and they're like [__] no monkeys
would have monkeys I don't I'm I'm just
going to I don't even think I can take
on one monkey everyone Tail's a game
changer tail a game changer everyone
thinks they can take take on like 10 20
to 8y olds but you you switch them to
monkeys cuz monkeys can [__] pounce
and they can jump very fast I don't even
think I can be one monkey all it takes
is one monkey on your face one monkey on
your face and done
yeah three four or five times stronger
than a human dude oh one okay 1.2 to 1.5
you literally read out the misconception
[__] sake I didn't read why did they
phrase the sentence like that with this
is not true at okay what if I just like
grabbed one kid okay let's say 10 kids
run at me I grab one kid throw them at
the kids to get as many of them out of
the way as I can grab another kid grab
them pile driver's head into the ground
presumably he's out by okay what if you
grab one of the kids by the leg and you
just like windmilled around
that honestly if you try to pick someone
up by the leg I haven't but if you try
to move someone by the leg it's very
hard Okay just grab by the arms sounds
like kill someone it's honestly very
it's much better than I know from
experience you I I feel like you have an
easier time for you like if he was
wearing clothes you pick him by the code
or shirt whatever you [__] launch
[__] launch but just shot his ass but
like if if you don't [__] knock him
out he's going to get back up and start
jumping you again and again I think that
will do as much D you can do the
cheesing thing that you do in fighting
games where you just keep doing the low
kick where you like low kick their leg
but you low kick their face like boom
boom keep them away just don't let them
get on you I think you can do it I
eventually they're going to start either
crying or get knocked down I don't think
throwing the kid into another kid is
going to do much damage to either into
the wall
right I mean I gu well okay what you're
in Final Destination there's no you can
do any tactic you like you just have
like no weapons right and you it's n 10
is my limit yeah i' say I think
I'd say eight to 10 I think 20 20 20 God
I'd love to see that that's range I
special I don't think you can like I
don't think you like Poss 8year olds
want to get beaten up contact trash
taste if it was 10-year-old it'd be a
lot less but 8-year-old that's pretty
sure what's the difference between those
two years can we get a can you show a
comparative age uh in picture uh
8-year-old versus adult 8-year-old
versus adult size just so cuz like
8-year-olds are pretty small I think
the're old they they grow through growth
eighty olds are small but I don't I
don't think you get a growth spot at age
10 oh it's pretty big difference really
bro that that is actually actually
pretty big that's pretty big that's
pretty big actually that's pretty you
can take on 20 okay 10 10 10 yeah right
I think you thinking about Tod is at
this I think think like 5year olds yeah
5year olds I could take like yeah
5-year-olds okay yeah 5-year-olds okay
10-year-old do 10-y old yeah average
child of a 10-y oldy they to grow a lot
more like in 138 CM image maybe 140 cm
yeah I feel like I would yeah maybe I'm
I'm overzealous over 32 kilos 140 cm so
what's what what's that like maybe about
that that's pretty big that's I think
wasze if one of them gets a good wow if
one of them gets a good nut shot on me
it's game over you know so I they are
they are at perfect nut height as well
how did this compation come out um
because we were seeing how how many
[__] shots these kids were tanking
how how old are they huh like 16 15 16
up to 18 and I'm like and I'm like what
because we could you could hear the
impact of every thought and sometimes
sometimes like people were getting like
obviously hit in the face they can tank
it in the face but it was like the body
shots right because with Tai with Muay
Thai cuz I've done a bit of Muay Thai
and when when you when you do a kick
it's almost like it's the same power as
just getting a b bat well it's like cuz
they like whip their feet right it's
almost like a whip motion you whip your
feet and you hear this impact and it
literally sounds like someone just took
a baseball bat and just [__] tried to
crack their real they
[Laughter]
whip visualize all the little bones in
your body to make a whip yeah and I
remember this one fight where this guy
just which which always which I guess
comes down to like the mental game as
well this one guy just seemed to be
tanking kicks and it did not seem to be
affecting him
no yeah to the point where like you
could visually see how red his body was
you you could see it and we were like
what how the hell is he still standing
and like he and he looked unfaced right
he looked unfaced and all it took was
like one kick in the fourth round and it
wasn't even the hardest kick but he just
like he just he just [__] fell over
went live and I'm like exists he's in
Thailand normally you can't just take
kicks free there a reason why you us a
Dodge yeah I I mean it's it's a bit sad
because we went to like a very local
stadium and normally you know this
stadium was famous for being able to all
the local tie people coming to watch but
it has very much been transformed to be
more Foreigner friendly the ticket
prices is not anything that uh you know
the locals can afford unfortunately um
but it was it was funny because they had
like whenever they introduced fighter
they'd have like a tie announcer and
they'd have like you know a typical like
English speaking announcer as well oh
wow and the ti the Tha nower was like
you know Thailand we are like very
respectful country we're like okay so
the next fighter is this person he grew
up from this province his name is this
how come they're really respectful here
but then when I'm trying to get in the
taxi it feels like there is just nothing
but disrespect yo when it comes to
martial arts that's where dude is that
where all the respect went what the heck
that's
xenophobia they were nice they hustle
and then you hand it over to like the
Foreigner and he's like and coming into
the Red
Corner the man from Thailand it's just
like we we love the shows with fire
butches his name it's just like the
sheer dichotomy between the energy
between how the you know how the Tha
fight it's Monday Monday mu Tha
night but uh like this there's one fight
that stood out to me wasn't anything
actually to do with the fight right
because there was this one fight where
it was it was I guess uh I think this
kid was like 16 or something like that
and imagine it it's a packed Stadium
right it's a packed Stadium everyone's
cheering on every single hit every punch
and this one voice just pierces through
everything and it's the kid's
mom oh no and and Jesus and like me and
my mate had bets on like who which
fighter would win and uh I bet like I
bet against that kid right and then just
seeing the mom uh just like just seeing
the mom and I I listened he was like no
no no hook left hook left UPA UPA no
Dodge Dodge and like and and just like
it that would drive me insane if my
mom's
back it almost made me [__] tear up
cuz like just like seeing the mom just
Port like I can't imagine how it is as a
parent seeing your kid in the ring
getting beat getting beat up man must be
horrible and just seeing the mom just
fully commit to supporting this kid um
who thankfully actually won his fight in
the end yeah [__] the other kid in his
[__] his mom wasn't there his mom wasn't
there that's why you should always go to
your sons or daughters games cuz they'll
win exactly they'll win power of parents
they they will win and uh they if if you
can hear them I I don't know if the kid
could hear the person or not um because
I don't I can't imagine how focused you
need to be on the ring yeah that K
probably had like a raging ball moment
where he like he heard the mom like I
have to do it for my family damn well
that was that was epic I highly
recommend going to more contact Sports I
I think I'm going to do it now as well
it's well next well we know what we're
doing next time we're in Thailand yeah
hell yeah and uh how many how many
eight-year-olds can we be in I said 10
you said eight you said I say 11 just a
oneup just a oneup sry